all right guys when you're going to buy
a baseball cap the first thing you have
to decide is are you going to go with
fitted or are you going to go with
snapback i'm gq style editor will welch
and i'm here at barneys with don c
king of the snapback and the designer of
just dawn
[Music]
when you launched just on it felt like
everybody at the time was wearing
fitteds and then you kind of came out of
nowhere with the snapbacks thing so uh
what were you thinking in that moment uh
it was bubbling within culture i felt
like the snapback brought more flair to
the product because uh you got a chance
to have like a little pop in the back
with a piece of hardware just from a
consumption standpoint snapbacks are way
cooler because you don't have to like go
to your store and be like hey i like
that yankees hat oh let me get these 13
hats for you to try on it's like let me
get that one one thing um that was wild
to see is how fast it went from
everybody wearing fitted like just threw
the [ __ ] in the garbage and went right
to snap back so were you anticipating
that kind of shift no not at all um i
think it's just like the
wave and culture and things come around
in cycles so you know now everybody i
feel like snapbacks are more popular i
could see a guy trying to be different
wearing a fitted now which some do yeah
so uh i like it that they both exist and
it's like it's your personal taste
whether or not you like the snapback
versus the fitting and one good thing
about the fitting cap is like a lot of
us the first time we ever wore a cap was
playing baseball and you want to be like
the pros and wear the fitted and so that
just continues from there that's the on
the field baseball cap as a fitted cap
other than that
i like adjustables because it's like
sometimes my hair is short sometimes my
hair is long
sometimes i want to wear my hat loose
sometimes i want to wear it tight so i
have that flexibility with an adjustable
right i got a question for guys with
small heads or
guys like me with a really big head
does it ever look funny if you're not
sort of like in the middle ground on the
adjustable like you had a dancy with
just a very i do believe that even
snapbacks should come in maybe like two
sizes right right for guys that wear
their hat backwards a lot is uh their
preference like is it better to go with
a fitted versus a snapback i think the
adjustable's better especially a don
because you got your gold buckle and tab
to stunt with right right it's almost
like you're hiding the big python brand
or you're letting people behind you see
you
it's sort of like
check my logo in the back
all right guys definitely let us know
what you think about snapback or fitted
in the comments section you heard it
from don c himself go to justdon.com for
more on the hats and subscribe to gque's
youtube channel
[Music]